water has many amazing properties its
surface tension enables things like bugs
to walk across it without sinking water
also becomes less dense as it freezes
which is why during winter lakes freeze
from the top down and life persists at
the bottom now scientists have observed
a bizarre quantum mechanical trick in
the smallest possible droplet of water
waters ability to form hydrogen bonds is
behind most of its extraordinary feats
water molecules are always bonding with
one another switching partners like
dancers in order to study these bonds
researchers performed low-temperature
experiments on a cluster containing only
six molecules the smallest droplet that
will form a 3d shape by distinguishing
the individual water molecules in the
cluster they observed a surprising
result two different molecules in the
cluster move in sync breaking two
different hydrogen bonds at the same
time the rotating molecules mesh like
gears in a watch here's where the
weirdness of quantum mechanics comes in
at the low temperatures used in this
experiment the molecules don't jiggle
with enough energy to even break one
hydrogen bond there is an energy barrier
between the two configurations that's
too high to scale but thanks to quantum
uncertainty there's still a chance that
the cluster will simply pop through that
energy barrier a bit like walking
through a wall that weird trick is known
as quantum tunneling this unexpected cog
like motion in the tiniest droplet shows
once again how plain old water continues
to serve up scientific surprises